i' like to remind members using devices
to mute them and to turn off sound to
avoid feedback and consider turning off
your video if you intend to use the
keyboard for taking notes the good sound
quality it's important for members to
speak clearly with some volume soft May
heard but hard to understand and the
microphon pick up sound very well and we
all need to be careful about rustling
papers inside conversations we will be
muted at the lunch break we expect a
lunch break today um and we have Able
Body committee members who have now got
the mute button under control and you
will handle that
here we are YouTube streaming I believe
we
are uh and there's pre-registration
information for the day that has been
provided uh to me for the first hearing
um if you are online and want to
register you may do so but if you want
to speak um you will have to raise your
hand at the end of my taking comments
because I'm not aware on my list that
you want to speak in regards to this
meeting being conducted in this hybrid
manner as chair of the house law house
election law committee I find that due
to the state of the emergency declared
by the governor as a result of the
covid-19 pandemic and in accordance with
house rule 67 and the governor's
emergency order 12 for to executive
order
20204 that this body is authorized to
meet electronically this is a public
hearing on Bill's reverge the committee
and schedule for the calendar an
executive session is also scheduled for
today and that will be occurring on the
bills noticed in the calendar please
note that there is no physical for
members of the public to observe and
listen contemporaneously to this meeting
however in accordance with the emergency
order I am confirming that all members
of the committee and legislative staff
have the ability to to communicate
contemporaneously during this meeting
and through the zoom electronic meeting
platform and the public has the
opportunity to get listen
contemporaneously and if necessary uh
participate by the zoom platform or
telephone all necessary access
information has been made available in
the house calendar and through the
electronic calendar on the general court
website the notice for this meeting
complies with our house rules and RSA
91a and anyone who has problems access
in this meeting should call 271 3600 or
email HCS ledge.
state.us in the event we learn that the
public is unable to access this meeting
the meeting will be adjourned and
rescheduled all hes that are taken
during this meeting shall be done by
roll call and we will start the meeting
by taking a roll call attendance with
the chair realizing that the clerk is
not here so I'm going to go to this
handy list that I have and hopefully I'm
going to get everybody when you answer
if you could if you're attending
electronically if please let us know if
there's anybody else with you which for
some reason is required by the to no
representative mcdonal here
representative bran here representative
Sweeny
represent
here representative quy here
representative Wells is not here we
expect her at about 11 o'clock
representa excuse me was that my name it
was representative Cody yes I am here
thank you representative Ward uh here in
forsmith two family members in the
[Music]
house
I know representative Bon is here sorry
CH Madam chairman I didn't hear hear you
you're breaking up sometimes yes I am
present I'm uh calling in electronically
from home there's no one present in the
room with me there is one member of the
household elsewhere in the house thank
you thank you to
representative mic in front of me does
not appear to be on so I'm turning it
that creates more problems let me know
thank you
represent is that
here no what was that what was the name
representative
s I'm present I'm in my home office U my
husband is in the house but there's no
one in this room with me I I
representative
camera I'm present in my house in
Manchester with a couple family members
in the house thank you representative
lay I'm present in my home office I'm
alone in the office there's two people
um in the
house I'm in my home alone thank
you I'm presid home and there's another
family member in the house and
representative
Mir pres and alone thank you very kindly
thank you
representative um thank representative
for uh doing some clerk functions for me
pending my clerk wells's arrival um and
now before starting cacr 4 if you could
join me in a pledge of
aliance I pledge Al to flag United
States of
America stands one nation God
indivisible with liberty and justice for
all thank you to members of the public
for having our opening business eat into
the time for caca 4 caca 4 is the bill
on redistricting providing that an
independent redistricting commission
shall be established to draw boundaries
for state and federal Offices um it is
introduced by representative sht who
has not signed up to speak
um she has raised her hand from the
attendees
however okay let's recognize her because
she has um submitted written
testimony good morning can you hear me
we can representative
welcome thank you um for the record I am
Diane Shu Prime sponsor of cacr 4 uh I
represent marac 20 the towns of Pembrook
and Chichester I apologize for not
sending your committee notice of my
intent to testify via the calendar
entry going to send my entry yesterday
after my own committee
ended did not happen until after 5 pm
and the portal was closed by them so I
chose to just email you
folks my testimony and an amendment that
I'll be presenting so my apologies for
that um so I'll continue with my
presentation which will be fairly
brief uh the text of this constitute
amendment is identical to cacr
9 uh the the amended version which came
before the house last session after
being retained from the 2019
session um the election law committee as
it existed then held several bipartisan
subcommittee work sessions on that
Amendment and after reaching
comes to satisfy members on both sides
produce the cacr that you have you today
I hope that all of us can agree that
redistri can affect our own chances
being Mander
against on who does the
redistricting this cacr does not go into
the details of creating a
non-biased uh commission but would
simply put into the Constitution the
will of the people that one should be
cre uh leaving the details of that
commission to be placed into statute uh
the idea with that being that uh if the
commission details need to be tweaked
after its
creation that's more simply done through
statute rather than re amending the
Constitution uh I know this committee
has House Bill 121 before it which
proposes one method for Crea creting
such a commission and how that would
F at on HP
1221 uh I heard one legislator who was
opposed to that bill CIT lack of
constitutional Authority as his reason
for opposing that bill because it names
the legislature as the source for
redistricting that is one of the reasons
I bring this cacr for forward to have
the Constitutional enable such a
statute but in the final analysis this
would allow the voters of New Hampshire
to decide if this would be the fairest
way to
redistricting and that's my main
objective is to give the people the
right to weigh in on this
subject I have also presented for your
consideration uh the amendment Z
29h which just rewords the uh o
Clause just a little additional
language um which was actually suggested
by a
constituent um that concludes my
presentation if there are questions I
would be happy address
them thank you representative are there
any members of the committee here
present in the room that would like to
ask a
question
I'm not seeing any are there any
committee members online that would like
to ask a
question thank you representative I
don't believe I'm seeing any questions
and thank you for coming and just sign
on sometime today okay thank you very
much also signed up to speak on this is
a co- sponsor representative
Porter representative Porter welcome
representative thank you madam chair
something weird just came on my computer
screen and kind of freaked me out can
you hear me okay can we can hear you
great thank you uh good morning Madam
chair and members of the committee and
thank you for allowing me to testify for
the record I'm Marge reporter I
represent Hillsboro district one which
are the towns of antrum Hillsboro and
Windsor and it is for them that that I
joined with representative shu to
co-sponsor cacr
4 Hillsboro District 1 is a purplish red
District we are represented here in
conquered by two Democrats and two
Republicans both president Trump and
President Obama won here as did Governor
Hassen and Governor
sonunu my constituents want a fair open
and transparent system for redistricting
our state specifically they want an
independent redistricting commission to
do the work it's important to them how
do I know this because at last year's
town meeting the residents of Hillsboro
passed a resolution in support of the
establishment of such a commission I've
received a letter from the selectman
asking me to dis to support the
establishment of an independent
redistricting commission whenever it
comes before us
here we know that bills to establish a
redistricting commission had
overwhelming bipartisan support in the
past but the belief was that the con was
unconstitutional and it prevented them
from becoming law Madame chair and
members of the committee this is a
nonpartisan request from my purplish red
District it's time that we put the
voters of the
state allow them to make their wishes
known so we can hear them
thank you very much and I'll take
questions if you have any members in the
room that would like to ask a question
representative Bryant thank you madam
chair I'm uh welcome uh representative
Porter uh my question is what town was
it that passed the resolution Hillsboro
thank you any other questions for
members of the committee in
room I'm not seeing any any questions
from members of the committee attending
electronically
I'm not seeing any thank you
representative Porter for being with
here with us this morning also signed up
to speak on this bill is Louise
Spencer try
toote and actually somehow l torelli i
promoted you as a panelist so why don't
we go with
you
uh thank you Louise was not speaking is
that correct and and you've got me Liz
tanelli yes Liz if you miss torelli if
you could go ahead Louise is going to
speak but when I
promoted I promoted you instead so Lise
will be next thank you thank you um for
the record my name is Liz tentarelli I'm
president of the League of Women Voters
of New Hampshire a nonpartisan organiz
organization uh that is committed to
redistricting in a fair and nonpartisan
way um we have testified before in this
committee over the years we're here
again testifying in support this time of
cacr 4 um I have before me on the screen
an
amendment uh that I don't know if you
have discussed uh that doesn't have all
the details in it that the original Bill
did when I wrote my testimony yesterday
and sent it to you electronically I did
not have this amendment however I knew
there was one coming so I'd like to
address the concept of a redistricting
commission uh and then try to address
this um amended
version however I would direct you to my
testimony that
details the very negative negative
process that happened in 2011 that
resulted in lawsuits that made the
public very angry about the
redistricting process that's what we
want to avoid this year already there
are 15 States including two of our
neighbors Maine and Vermont and two
other states of the Northeast New York
and Rhode Island that have independent
redistricting
commissions and they adopted those
commissions because of the Public's
demand for a fair process in 2019 in the
uh Supreme Court case of rucho versus
North Carolina and Maryland the Supreme
Court basically said it's not up to us
to cure the problems of partisan
districting it is up to the states and
that's what I hope we will do here in
New
Hampshire um I'm sure everybody in this
room was as appalled as I was when on
January 23rd Steve stepanic running for
um a partisan uh leadership position
within his party um pointed out that one
party was in the majority and said
because of this we control redistricting
I can stand here today and guarantee you
that we will send a Conservative
Republican to Washington DC as a
congress person in
2022 no matter which party you were on
I'm sure you're appalled at the idea
that here is a leader in the party
saying we will gerrymander to ensure
congressional representation from one
party uh so it is in that spirit that I
ask you please to consider this bill as
a way to make sure the voters voices
will be heard
the voters that want Fair districting
they want their candidates to stand an
equal chance um no matter which party
they're from uh and this is an
opportunity to do that it calls for
transparency it calls for nonpartisan
criteria in this process so I thank you
for this opportunity to speak to you
again uh and I'd be glad to take
questions if you have any and I'd
certainly take questions uh
via email if you have any to my uh
written testimony thank you very much
thank you questions for members from the
committee president in the
room representative Bri thank you madam
chair since 2011 when the Republicans
were in charge of redistricting in the
state of New Hampshire have we only
elected Republican members to the
Congress uh thank you for that question
no in fact the reverse is true uh
redistricting that's done for partisan
purposes is not necessarily
successful uh the districts could be
drawn differently so that there would be
that outcome uh in fact in District One
the position of Congress person has
flipped back and forth from Republican
to Democrat several times over those
years
um there are certainly other diff
differences the state senate has been
perhaps more impacted and certainly the
executive Council in New Hampshire has
been more impacted by deliberate
districting of packing and cracking from
2011 any other members of the committee
from the room with questions for miss
tendell any members of the committee
attending electronically have
questions I'm not seeing any thanks for
coming and we did get the email with
your testimony so thank you thank
you um also signed up to speak as I
mentioned before is Lise Spencer Louise
I actually figured out how to promote
you to panelists this time when I said
your name welcome Louise
Spencer
morning
I just I just unmuted thank you madam
chair and um thank you to the committee
members it's it's nice to see everybody
and I greatly appreciate your work here
um my name is Louise Spencer I'm from
Conquer New Hampshire and I am a
co-founder of the Kent Street Coalition
we're an all volunteer Grassroots
advocacy
organization um which at this point has
members from across the state and I
would say that uh all of universally our
members support and in fact actively
advocate for nonpartisan redistricting
it's one of our our top priority issues
um like but today I I am here speaking
on my own behalf from my own
experiences and one of which is like
many of you I've uh I have my own
political leanings and I'm not afraid to
fight as hard as I can for the things I
believe in fighting in a in a peaceful
way um but I do believe in a fair fight
and I believe that competition usually
brings us closer to compromise and the
best path forward and that's why I'm
here today I ask you to support cacr 4
which would enshrine this concept of
fairness into our state constitution uh
making clear that the right to choose
our elected representatives
belongs solely to the people and not to
a party or to vested special interests
we I believe must unequivocally declare
that anyone buying for the privilege to
represent the goodest citizens of our
state uh must be prepared to come
forward with good ideas and intent not
with jiggered maps all but guaranteeing
a win if like me you have gone door too
knocking you've heard it many times over
and over again probably as I have that
voting doesn't matter and that no one
cares what I think we hear cries to
throw the bums out drain the swamp um
cries for term limits and these are the
cries of frustration by people who don't
think their voice or their vote
matters uh too often the culprit too
often the right actually and too often
the culprit is um partisan Jerry
mandering um the election is already
determined before a single vote is cast
um or it's determined in a primary where
the winning candidate of one party is
all but guaranteed a win in the general
election we see that in the US House
only about 60 seats are considered truly
competitive the others have been favored
to drawn have been drawn to favor
incumbents of one party or the other
that means that in
86% of these districts the results have
already been declared and decided I'm
not declared I'm sorry but decided by
the November
election um and this is a problem of
both parties the lore of power is just
too tempting elections are supposed to
be a check on that Temptation not an
endorsement of it maps are drawn to
protect parties to protect incum to
protect special interests uh to protect
everyone but the voter with cacr 4 we
have the opportunity to change that to
restore fairness and power to Those whom
our con Constitution is supposed to
protect and that's the voter so I I
thank you for taking my testimony and um
again would incourage support for this
bill in a firmly
bipartisan um way
so thank you and I'm happy to take
questions thank you questions for Miss
Spencer representative Mooney thank you
very much M chair Miss Spencer are you
able to hear me I can't hear you I'm so
sorry
representative quite all right could you
hear me now Miss Spencer yes I can okay
I apologize for that I see your email is
sent uh very briefly to us with your
support just wondering if you could tell
me again the name of your organization
yes it's the Kent Street Coalition that
Kent I'm just taking notes for today yes
that's right thank you sure
yes any other questions from members
here in the room
representative thank you madam chair uh
thank you for joining us Miss Spencer I
I know you said that you were speaking
on behalf of yourself but that your
organization uni universally approved
this uh this
resolution what is the membership number
of your organization how many members do
you do you
represent um as I said I I am actually
speaking here on my own behalf but I
wanted to convey that our members are
strongly in support of redistricting and
we've committed a a lot of hours and
energy um on behalf of of the um working
toward um partisan R nonpartisan
redistricting um so our membership is um
I like to think of it as kind of centric
Circles of Engagement we have um active
members that um regularly um show up
with us to testify or to hold signs to
do that sort of Engagement that's about
120 to about 150 people we have uh about
500 on our mailing list and we have
about 1,200 on our Facebook
page thank you further questions um Miss
Spencer just in in follow up to that
question on your organization is Ken
Street Coalition registered yet with the
state with the Secretary of State's
office I know it wasn't last year no
we're not we are um a form you're not
really organization you're an informal
group of people who are using a
different name as an
organization we're an informal group of
people that is correct we i' like to say
that we're a coalition of
individuals and we are all
volunteer um we do not have any paid
Staffing or um and our focus is on
action all right but the reality is
you're a group of volunteers there's no
registration of an organization with the
secretary of stes office that's
absolutely correct yes all right thank
you other questions for committee
members here in the room or attending
online all right thank you thank you for
coming nice to see you I was wondering
when we see you at a public hearing wel
yeah I've had some conflicts on Fridays
so I'm trying to uh rearrange things so
that I can be present more often so
thank you so much for taking my
testimony all right thank you also
signed up to speak this morning is
Olivia zinc U Miss zinc you are with us
so welcome thank you uh Madam chair and
members of the election law committee
for the record my name is Olivia zinc
I'm the executive director of open
democracy action we're a nonpartisan
nonprofit Pro voter organization of
35,000 members open democracy's mission
is really fixing democracy specifically
campaign Finance Fair maps and honest
elections and here today um I'm uh from
my home in Franklin and I have my my
orange badge on if you can see it um I
am um speaking in favor of cacr for this
Constitutional Amendment because voters
need to pick politicians politicians
should not pick voters redistricting
process um should be done fa and
fairly I want to speak to the November
7th 2006 constitutional amendment to R
districting that our towns had uh that
our communities passed and this really
called on towns with a significant
population to have their own
representative um 10 years ago
legislators ignored our
Constitution and the voters wishes 62
towns out of 152 were denied their own
representation I want you to know that
voters supported this Constitutional
Amendment um in 200 six 240,000 voters
to 100,000 voters so this was favored by
the by a large majority of people um Liz
tantarelli from the league um quoted the
party leadership but I wanted to just
comment that I really hope that this
committee the special committee on
redistricting and the whole legislative
body will be accountable to the voters
and not party
leadership and I'm going to quote Daniel
Webster um in his quote The People's
Government is made for the people made
by the people and accountable to the
people partisan Jerry Mandarin is
perpetuated by Bad actors of any party
and is bad for towns it's bad for the
voters and no matter what happens I
think it's really important that voters
have faith in the process um and they
believe in an honest and in um
government of
Integrity executive District Council 2
is a district that really can
demonstrate um what happens when you
pack uh Democratic voters into one
District um I do also want to um 10
years ago when when the house passed
redistricting um according to the house
journal and um Senator uh Republican I
representative David Pierce I wanted to
call him a senator because that's what
he was after he was a member of your
committee but 10 years ago he cited in
the house Journal that there was a
24-hour notice for the public to give
com to give public input on the plan and
I think it's really um as you all look
at this bill and look at the
redistricting process moving forward I
hope you will um care for a
transparent process that allows voters
input and allows New Hampshire to be
represented Fairly New Hampshire has a
proud tradition of civic participation
and we really hope um you have a chance
for a fair
electoral uh process and for that we
urge you all to pass on cacr 4 and I'm
happy to take any questions thank you
Miss Z are there any questions from
committee members here in the committee
room question from members of the
committee attending electronically
I'm not seeing any thank you very much
for being with us this
morning is there that is the end of the
people that I have signed up um to speak
on this bill is there anybody else that
would like to speak to this
bill I'm not seeing any so I'm going to
close the public hearing on
CAC
R4 and open the public hearing on our
next matter which is
hb77 this is the bill requiring town and
City Clerks to provide daily
notification to the Secretary of State
of any filings for an elective office um
I have signed up to speak on this
representative bone who is the sponsor
of this bill representative bone welcome
to the election law committee good
morning
representative bone you were with us yes
thank you I just got
rejoined and thank you um I'm Ralph bow
Hillsboro District Point Town litfield
i' like to preface this with Now for
Something Completely
Different okay this is this is an act
requiring town and City Clerks to
provide electronic dailying notification
to the Secretary of State this bill I
was planning on doing this some years
ago and I keep forgetting so anyway this
is my seventh
term this bill was brought up because
some Town clerks are waiting until the
last day of filing before sending in the
documentations documents to Secretary
State how you know the Secretary State
records daily the filings of all office
C candidates this is a way for residents
to see see who or if anyone has filed
talking to my town clerk she was under
the impression that these documents must
be mailed daily even if this is a rule
by the Secretary of State it is not
being followed and even for example by
mail especially today it is not very
timely for example I filed the first day
my town clerk mailed it that day picked
up by the Postal Service the following
Mo morning it was Monday before it
showed up in the Secretary of State's
report my town clerk thinks this is a
very good idea and a comment was doesn't
everybody have email all us you would
like this to even go further and a lot
of documents to be scanned and
electronically sent up all of the
candidates filed the Secretary of
State's office except for state
representative and their filings
appeared that day on the Secretary of
State's database why should our office
of State Rep be second rate to other
offices and how much time will this take
by the town clerk 30 seconds the $2 fee
will easy pay for any extra time they
use and in the towns that this is
happening in there are only a couple of
candidates and also from talking some
years ago to the Secretary of State's
office some Town clerks have forgotten
to send the documents in this will make
it easy for the Secretary of State to
follow up on paperwork and
representative Rick lad who town that
this happened to has sent in testimony
on how this occurred in his town so
thank you and I will take any
questions question representative Teran
M thank you taking the question so what
what's the current law on this um they
only have to do at the end of the F
period or is it
weekly
elaborate uh can I repeat that please
please yes so what's the current law on
on Secretary of State
um well I don't the Lord doesn't say but
the secretary of state has a ruling
telling the the town clerks to mail in
the documents
daily okay but there's no law saying
that and this isn't for male we want
them we want the names to be sent up
electronically so you know and I know
who else may be running for that office
on a daily basis the documents can then
have to be sent in should be sent in
daily as the Secretary of State's office
has
ruled thank you
representative uh yeses hear me yes in
your opinion do most Town clerks have
access to
email I I don't know who doesn't have
access to email and it' be
electronically as recommended by the
Secretary of State and it's some Cas
they can do it by phone okay whatever
method that the Secretary of State
determines and like I said and like our
town clerk said who doesn't have
email just a quick followup so if if
this fill were to pass then would that
also require the Secretary of States
office to update that
database on a daily basis yes just like
every other
office
any questions from committee members
attending electronically representative
Bergeron thank you madam chairman uh
representative um there actually is a
state law currently it's RSA 655 colon
18 which states that each city or town
clerk shall forward each Declaration of
candidacy filed with him or her to the
Secretary of State on the day of filing
of the same uh rather than introduce a
whole new section uh could we just modif
ify the existing law and say that they
shall submit that to the Secretary of
State on the day of filing
electronically and by
mail and I I personally I didn't I found
this I found 15 and that's what I
modified or the Los did um a AOL OLS
anyway did so yeah if you think it's a
better place please go right ahead but I
think you know the filing electronically
and follow up with the paperwork this is
what I I
intended okay thank you for the question
Madam chair question go ahead
representative B and uh by
electronically am I correct in assuming
that also includes by facts if a town or
city clerk chose to do it that way
rather than by email sure I mean that's
what whatever this that's why I left it
open for whatever the Secretary State
thinks it's convenient and the clerks
thinks it's convenient thank you very
much thank other questions from
committee members attending
electronically I'm not seeing any any
further questions from anybody here in
the room representative
Mooney okay representative B good
morning
yes thank you I hear you thank you thank
you for taking my question my thought is
um say for example there are no filings
on a particular day uh does the town
clerk is he or she required to take any
action and is the law clear on that
point or does it need to be clear on
that point no I don't think it need to
be clear I mean people that file it
should be a file a daily filing I if
nobody files then you know in some cases
where towns only have like in litfield
there's only two people four people the
most are going to file yeah so it's not
going to be a daily filing and also I
see represent Mooney you and I are both
missing a commission
meeting on me thank
you
representative thank you madam chair uh
so without the word
electronic in this wording here of of
the
bill does that mean that a clerk could
interpret this to me just mail it as is
done now which you find to be somewhat
slow in some cases so electronic is not
in there they could mail it they could
they could phone it in they could carry
a pigeon it
in well on line five of the bill it says
such summary summary shall be submitted
electronically and it shall include the
name and address of any candidate who
has filed the title doesn't say
electronically and I noticed that but
the the bill itself on line five states
electronically further
questions I'm not seeing any thank you
representative for being here with us
this
morning I Al no one else has signed up
to speak on this bill I do have a Mr
Healey who has his hand raised and the
Secretary of State um I'm going to
promote repres Mr Healey uh to join us
with a comment on
hb77 welcome Mr
Healey hi uh Daniel hilly Derry town
clerk um I've talked to a few Town
clerks uh we all seem to like this bill
I think it's a good idea to send the
electronic uh filings daily
um I know right now my office does
forward everything up to the Secretary
of State on a daily basis but mail can
take a few days and I hate seeing um you
know when the filing perod ends on a
Friday that on a Wednesday or a Thursday
the next week names are added to the
list I think the Secretary of State
really should have all the the names of
the people on the you know the deadline
at 5:00 pm and know who has signed up
and know what to be expecting in the
mail um and I thank uh representative
berson for for stating that RSA um if
clerks aren't doing that aren't
following that I think the Secretary of
State should be following up with them
um if they're not sending it daily um
but that is something that our office
does uh I know many clerks all the
clerks that I talk to have been been
following that but I do think the
electronic uh filing is is a good
idea um I also do think that on a day if
there are no filings that the town clerk
should send something up saying uh the
date and not we have no filings for this
date to report uh it just kind of
reinforces um the transparency with when
when people file but um I would be in
support of of this
bill than you any
questions anybody have any questions
from Mr
hey I'm not seeing any thanks for being
with us again Mr Hy nice to hear from
you thank
you Deputy scanland has signed up to
speak on this bill um Deputy scanland
welcome if you un mute I think we're all
set great thank you chair whenever I get
recognized it boots me off and then it
takes a little time for me to come back
up again but I you the master of Zoom
meetings because Deputy scanland ran
Zoom meetings this summer for the safe
elections committee that what was the
most attendees we had at one of them was
over 400 we had to suspend one day so if
anybody can promote and unmute its
Deputy well thank you madam chair I'm
here um I'm David scanland deputy
secretary of state and you know I would
like to say that you know we I think we
would be happy to receive information on
who has filed for state representative
or delegate to the Republican convention
uh from the town Clerks the day of those
filings um I would like to say that that
most Town clerks have been getting that
information uh to us in the mail on the
day of the filing so there have been a
few instances where uh some of the
clerks have batched them and sent them
uh every three or four days or you know
even at the end of the uh filing
period and there have been some
instances where filings have got or you
know dro behind a desk and not found for
some time after the fact and those
situations do cause problems um just a
couple things I'd like to mention is
that not not every clerk's office is
open every day uh during the filing
period and I'm sure in a large town like
Derry um you know they meet their
offices open every day uh for normal
business hours but when you get up into
the North Country there are Clerk's
offices that may be open a couple of
days a week and and not even for a full
day so um you know I think we have to
recognize uh that the hours aren't
consistent um and in terms of receiving
the information
electronically uh we may have to think
about how that process would work and
and uh you know maybe change it a little
bit over time uh it's important for us
to receive the hard copy the signed de
aration of candidacy uh we review it in
this office to make sure that the
information is correct uh and the
candidate is actually qualified to run
for the office and occasionally there
are a few that you know that slip by
that scrutiny but um you know we don't
we don't necessarily uh have that
information until we receive the signed
declaration so what we receive
electronically at least to start could
be posted as an unofficial list of
filings and then once we receive the
actual sign
declarations uh we can change that uh to
an official
list um but again I just I want to re
reiterate that most clerks uh in New
Hampshire uh do their job very well and
they get these filings uh uh in the mail
as required by the statute on the day
that they're filed and they're just a
few rare instances where uh uh you know
some of the clerks don't uh actually
follow that process and bat them or send
them to us on the last day and when
those happen we do follow up so with
that I'd be happy to answer any
questions question for Deputy scan for
members from the representative
grow
scan would a scan copy of the sign
declaration be adequate for you to make
an official uh
review report official that was sent in
on the same day
well that that would certainly
help other questions for Deputy SC
representative ter roian thank you madam
chair thank you depy scaming a question
so when you get the El now you get the
electronic
trans transfer email whatever it is to
your office you will update that even as
an
unofficial candidate till such time you
get the the Declaration of py the high
is that
correct thank you uh for the question
you broke up on me quite a bit I I think
I understood the
question right now whenever we receive
the filings though the filings get
posted on our website uh that same day
um so when we received the mail uh you
know we open them up revie review the
filings get them up on the website as
having received the uh the documentation
um and I'm sure that if there was if
this information was provided to us
electronically that we would get that
information up the day that we receive
it followup question representative
thank you so follow Deputy scalan so
until you get that whether it be a fact
or a written copy in the mail of the
Declaration of feny in review that you
don't list it then on Secretary of State
website showing that candidate until
that is kind of reviewed is that
correct U the the the information that
we receive goes up on the website the
day that we receive
it we review that we review the the the
filings we make sure that uh you know
that the uh candidates are uh on the
checklist in the town that uh you know
they're domiciled in and running for
office from
uh before we post
them thank you further questions from
committee members for
scan I'm not seeing any is there anybody
else who would like to speak in regards
to
hb77 please raise your
hand I'm not seeing anybody so I'm going
to close the public hearing on HB
77 it is
1022 our next hearing will be on HB
285 at 10:30 so we have a few minutes of
recess thank you
everybody
[Music]
e
C
the
Denise Denise she has she
has
Denise
we are
[Music]
unmuted
all right representative
Le
all right it is 10:30 this is the New
Hampshire house election law committee
we have scheduled for public hearing
House Bill 285 this is Rel relative to
the verification of voter checklist this
Bill modifies the procedure for ongoing
verification of the information
contained in voter checklist uh the
prime sponsor represent Leon is with us
to introduce this bill and speak to us
about it welcome
representative you should be all set to
go here uh thank you madam chairman and
thank you honorable members of the El
house election law committee for the
record I am representative Erica Lon
Rockingham district 6 Derry and I am the
prime sponsor of HB
285 how many dead people are still on
the checklist in your town the dairy
supervisors of the checklist removed
over 40 dead voters this fall that
weren't caught by the current system how
many slipped through the cracks in your
town or city and over the whole state
this isn't because of lack of effort
from our supervisors but there's a
culture of following the minimum prescri
prescription of the law so as not to
disenfranchise anybody and I understand
why they do that but these good
intentions lead to a bloated checklist
one with costs both in dollar figures
and in the right to cast one whole vote
HB 285 will step up that minimum
standard bringing it in line with towns
like London which take a more proactive
approach and actively use the
notification
system voter disenfranchisement is a
serious issue our checklist protects the
right of each inhabitant in the state to
have an equal right to vote in any
election which is spelled out in the New
Hampshire Constitution article 11 part 1
allowing duplicate or out ofd names on
the checklist violates this right
because this dilutes the equality of
each valid Vote many towns and cities
follow the minimum requirements
concerned about the risk of potentially
moving a valid voter that is
understandable but it misses a larger
Point leaving invalid voters on the
checklist means that there's a honey pot
for dishonest people and if this leads
to fraud it will deny equal
representation to the quality ified
voters this too is
disenfranchisement HB 285 provides the
checks needed to protect this sacred
right for each voter to cast one whole
vote as you look through this bill the
cost of annually running the list
through the national change of address
system will come to mind I'm sure the
cost of more mailings will too I believe
that we can and should invest in free
and fair elections however I believe
that fixing our bloated checklist will
save money too as you're well aware many
voting procedures like the count of
voting booths is prescribed based upon
the number of Voters on the checklist
the 4,000 residents flagged as
permanently moved from dairy and my
check of 24,000 names on the checklist
represents one six of the list that's a
lot of extra capacity at elections which
comes at a real cost we do catch those
voters on the 10-year clean but that's a
safety valve and not a solution HB 285
presents a solution to drive ongoing
maintenance of the checklist add
standardization of addresses which is
needed and to check the list annually
for permanent moves the cost of HB 285
should be neutral but the cost of not
passing HB 285 could mean that your vote
counts as only 56 of a vote I urge you
to vote op to pass and I'm available to
take
questions thank you representative for
your testimony questions from committee
members in the
room representative
thank you m Madam chair and thank you uh
representative L for bringing this
forward do you have um an idea of the
opinion on the uh Town clerks uh and how
they feel about this the town clerks
Association or anything like that have
you have you worked with them on
this um thank you very much for the
question representative PR of O'Brien I
as I was working through the checklist
this summer and identified some of these
some of these voters that should have
come off the list I worked closely with
our town clerk Our Town mod moderator
and supervisor of the checklist um these
are things that are normally caught at
the 10-year Purge and it's something
that is a lot harder for them to follow
they appreciated my efforts and they saw
these opportunities for improvement and
they shared my excitement about the
ability to improve this process in a way
that would not be overly burdensome and
would incre would um would improve these
check list and improve the
Integrity thank you thank you thank you
questions from Members attending
electronically representative
Lane yes thank you madam chair um
representative I notice that there's a
provision that you it's to be sent into
the DMV well the DMV has a a task under
this bill have you talked to them and
are they okay with that
because um my experience is sometimes
otherwise um thank you very much for the
question representative I actually did
not talk to the DMV about this um I I
apologize for that oversight but this is
something where it is important to be
able to get those change of address in
my discussions with the moderator and
with other people there already is an
ongoing back and forth but it hasn't
been codified and so it's something
where the data is sometimes passed back
and forth but this the information does
not always get transmitted back and
forth so I believe that this would be a
good step for
clarification thank you representative I
see you have your hand up but you're on
the phone so I think you have to hit
star six anybody star six or Star n
thank
you thank you madam
chair um I uh just wondered uh I wanted
to thank you representative for your
testimony and I just wanted um to get a
little clarification on the numbers and
Barry you said there you discovered 40
people who had recently passed away who
are on the checklist and then also
mentioned the number 4,000 and I'm
guessing I'm sorry if I didn't follow
you clearly enough but I'm guessing that
you found something like um about 4,000
people who had moved out of town and
were still on the checklist is is that
right thank you very much for the
question representative yes I did
identify I identified 100 potential vot
voters who had passed away there were um
several dozen that had been caught by
this three-point check system right now
death records when they match the voter
name date of birth and the town of
residence are transmitted automatically
to the checklist and that's a
three-point match when there's a
two-point match because somebody has
moved to a nursing home or another
temporary facility or they die out of
their Hometown it misses that
three-point match and those two-point
matches are a serious point of
consideration especially es especially
with nursing homes involved so those 42
voters uh were followed up by the
supervisor of the checklist they found
death notices and the procedure in HB
285 would would codify that and make it
so that the towns would be notified
about potential two-point matches and
they could further investigate those in
order to better clear the voter lists in
dery the 4,000 voters who had moved we
have some very very large apartment
complexes and we do have a relatively
High turnover rate in town these are
voters that I'm not saying that they
would have voted I'm just saying that
right now the way that they're cleared
off is on the 10-year Purge and we are
getting ready to do that right after the
Census Data this year in Derry this
takes the better part of the year for
them to do the 30-day notifications and
to clear out people who have moved out
of town and haven't voted in the in the
previous elections this is a process
that is slow Bur some and does leave a
lot of residents who move out of towns
as large and um and transient as dairy I
I know that our town is doing a
phenomenal job but I think that we can
give them better tools through the rsas
and through HB
285 thank you thank you thank you any
other questions from committee members
attending
electronically in the room
representative it thank you madam chair
thank you representative for taking my
question in in the process of doing your
research for this uh Bill have you seen
any data that indicates for same day
registrations particularly in a town
like yours where you have a lot of
apartment complexes where people come
and go what percentage of those voters
May uh have moved out of town say in in
an election period or even on a yearly
basis there any data that shows how many
same day registrations are back on the
list again in
town uh thank you for your question
representative and that is a very
poignant question I don't have that
information because um the the data by
the time it came through um it was it
was harder to correlate that and check
that against those numbers that is
something that I could look into if you
will not be executing this soon I can
get that information to the committee
and also speaking to the previous
Representatives comment I can get in
touch with the DMP and see see what
their opinion is and share that with you
as well but I I are you worried
representative toosan about people
losing their vote because they're
removed from the checklist and then
coming back on because they moved to a
different apartment in dairy or within a
town or are you worri concerned more
about um potential validity of those
same day
voters it's the
validity thank you thank you
um I that that's not within the scope of
this bill but it looks I from perusing
the bills that you have in front of you
I think that there are already some
wonderful bills to address that to your
committee thank you thank you any other
questions from committee members here in
the room
or attending
electronically representative
layout I'm not seeing any thank you very
much for your presentation of the bill
and if answering questions I also have
signed up to speak on HD
285 Ellis Robinson
and
and and you should be with us and you
are unmuted
welcome Mr Robinson welcome if you can
unmute um thank you very much I'm sorry
got momentarily disconnected um and it's
Ms Robinson um but I did want to just uh
thank you very much for seeing me and um
hearing to hearing my comments today
excuse me I'm trying to get rid of that
there we go much better thank you thank
you sorry
um I am uh pleased with the bill itself
as far as it goes I think that every
every one of the Town clerks would agree
that we want to have the best
information possible as long as it
doesn't put a huge boatload of work on
them however I would like to say uh to
request consideration of two additional
things one is that um in section four uh
1A there's a mention of what the voter
database would
include and right now the voter database
as accessible does not include date of
registration and that information would
be very helpful there's always an
interest from candidates as well as from
organizations and making sure that new
voters are familiar with if they come
from out of state with how New Hampshire
uh election laws work and how our
government works and it would be very
helpful to know that right now it's a
very conversome uh hand process to be
able to find that out and including that
date would be very
helpful the other piece I would
encourage is uh I suspect there's always
an interest in making sure that voting
information follows the
voter however it's rare that that
actually happens so for example my
husband and I live lived in conquer for
a couple of years and voted there we now
live in
Grantham um all of our voter
information
disappeared uh when we
re-registered in uh
Grantham so it would be very helpful if
uh more attention could be paid to when
somebody has moved within the state that
that information on how they've been
voting would be
available thank you for the opportunity
to speak to you and if you have any
questions I'm happy to answer them thank
Miss Ellis
representative thank you madam chair are
you a town clerk or involved in
elections in your community I didn't I'm
sorry if I missed some of the
introduction yes I work I work with a
lot of the I'm not um a town clerk I
have worked with candidates lot in our
community yes okay other questions from
committee members here in the room or
committee members attending
online I'm not seeing any thank you very
much melis for joining us here today
thank you for hearing me also signed up
to speak on this bill as representative
Thomas representative Thomas joins us in
the room today representative Thomas Co
is a co-sponsor of the bill welcome see
thank
you morning and thank you chair Griffin
and committee members for giving me an
opportunity top support
hb25 as you know I a co-sponsor to the
record my name is dou
represent and also Vice chair the
science technology comme on speak uh
it's my strong belief that having an
accurate B registration list is
necessary and
critical uh to ensure in confidence with
the voting public that only those who
can legally vote in our state in federal
elections do
so this bill deals with the process of
keeping the voter list up to date on a
regular basis of has already provided
details I just want to add some
background information I was interested
in similar idea and when I learned that
was working on this well I met with her
and we combined our forces to come up
with this bill I arranged a meeting with
our with lary's Town supervisor of
checklist Miss
chur and we went over our ideas and much
my pleasant surprise I learned that lary
was already doing the practices that we
were thinking about recommending so
I'm I'm proud to announce that although
this is not going to see it we had good
good elction results in process has got
smoothly and I for a fact that
this has regular meetings to update the
checklist so I believe these processes
are a good foundation that perhaps old
towns might like to do and that's one
reason why we like to codify this to get
into state law also had a conversation
with our town clerk Cheryl Ferell who I
believe I
think chair presid of Association and I
had a conversation with her last night
she
said well this bill truly was a
bipartisan effort
knation and she gr draft Bill to
complete agreement what we I'm try to
say that uh you know I know that the um
that the team inary work diligently to
keep the checklist updated and I hope
that this process in bill can give
guidance to
others same thing so I think it's a
positive step and I hope that
thee takes us good
sign thank you thank you representative
Thomas questions for representative
Thomas from members in the
room questions for representative Thomas
from Members attending
electronically I'm not seeing any thank
you representative Thomas for joining us
today
representative Thum
up is there any other attendee here who
would like to speak in regards to this
bill
is there anybody else who'd like to
speak in regards to HB
285 man here if I could uh David
scanland deputy secretary of state um I
just like to say you know I I I don't
see anything in this bill that is a
problem for us to do but I would like to
just State um the process that we
currently have and the most fundamental
thing about maintaining the checklist in
New Hampshire is that we have locally
elected officials that maintain the
checklist the only individuals that are
authorized to put names on the checklist
or take names off of the checklist are
locally elected supervisors of the
checklist or in case of cities there may
be a board of registers uh for that
purpose um the division of Vital Records
is a division within the Secretary of
State's office so we do receive the
death data uh of uh of uh New Hampshire
citizens that pass away um whether
they're in state or whether they are out
of state that information is transferred
I believe it goes to the clerk's office
who then make that information we should
make that information available to the
supervisors of the checklist so that
they can confirm that those individuals
did in fact pass away and that they are
voters uh in the
town um so that already happens I
believe that there is uh uh currently
exercises utilizing the the Postal
Service change of address uh uh to
notify local election officials of
potential moves of Voters um there is
nothing in there that is automatic that
the Secretary of State make those
changes because again the only ones
authorized to uh uh make changes to the
voter checklist are uh supervisors of
the check list it's also important to
understand that the checklist is
dynamic it is changing minute to minute
uh voters moving in registering voters
passing away and being removed voters
moov so it is always in a state of flux
and because of that there is always
going to be uh uh you know information
on voters that may no longer be
qualified either because they've died or
or because they've moved I know that our
office spends a great deal of time uh
reviewing the names on the checklist
looking for duplicate matches and when
they can be confirmed make sure that
that information is cleaned up and as
the sponsor of the bill mentioned uh we
will be conducting a purge of the
checklist uh after the census is
completed and uh that will remove I
won't say it will remove any vote who
has not been active for two election
Cycles or four-year period uh will
receive a 30-day letter sent to them by
the supervisors of the checklist which
is a request for information are you
still are you still in town uh and and
should remain on the checklist and if
there is no response to that 30-day
letter then th those names are uh are
removed so after a purge we see a pretty
dramatic drop in the increase of names
on the checklist and then usually what
happens is the following election cycle
the numbers jump right back up again
because the voters names who have been
removed from the list surface somewhere
and re-register to vote uh usually on
the day of the
election um so I would uh Madam chair it
might be helpful at some point to have
our hav office give a presentation on
the uh centralized voter database that
we have how it's maintained you know
what information it contains that uh I
think that would be really useful
information for the committee and I
would be happy to set that up and with
that I'd be happy to answer any
questions thank you Deputy scan we're
gonna probably take you up on that auor
um questions for Deputy scanland from
committee members room questions
committee members attending
electronically
question I do thank you uh Madam chair
and thank you secretary scandin for
taking my question I just have a quick
question do you have to have a post
office address in order to be eligible
to
vote uh you have to provide when you
register to vote you have to provide
your domicile address and your mailing
address the domicile address should be
the physical
location um where a person lives um ma
the mailing address can be a post office
box
followup Madam
here uh do you have to have a post
office box we have people in my
constituency who don't have Post Office
boxes or any fixed
address representative word you dropped
off at the end you have constituents who
don't have a post office box or or a
fixed domicile their home houseless
people
B the if I understand the question
correctly the domicile address can also
be the mailing address um so a person
does not have to provide a post office
box to be able to register to be on the
checklist as a voter uh but they can use
a post office box as their mailing
address as long as they provide a
physical address for the
doic thank
you the questions from anybody in the
room Deputy scen I I do have a question
it goes
to just when the most registrations
occur in the state I live in a community
GS down which also has
um I won't say transient but a lot of
departments with people moving around
not a dairy but certainly a lot and you
mentioned that most of the registrations
are on Election Day so is is there a
ball park for what the percentage of
registrations are that are occurring
during the year as compared to on
election
day uh I would be happy to try and get
that information for you I you know I I
ass to recall that in any given election
there might be 10% that actually
register on the day of the election 10%
of the voters on the checklist and you
know I would say that that that is a
high figure when you compare to the
registrations that take place uh
otherwise in the town clerk's office or
at supervisor sessions in the balance of
the year um I'll try and get that number
for I see if I can break that out thank
you wuty the reason I ask that is
because I know in my community amount of
registrations either directly before or
on on Election Day
is and this bill is addressing issue of
correcting that list sort
of where we have to get to the point
where it's the bigger process
maintaining
is there also a piece that the Secretary
of State's office has thought about in
regards to how to maintain the list in
getting people to
register as they move I mean because
that's really what's going on like in a
community like Dairy to a great extent
nobody's re-registering when they they
move how do has this the office thought
at all about that because it seems to me
make it a lot easier for our communities
if we could sort of get that information
out there
there's there's no requirement that a
voter has to let the town know that
they're skipping Town they're leaving um
we do have a have a line on the voter
registration form so that if a voter uh
registers in a new town or a different
ward in a city that they can provide the
last location uh that they were a voter
and that information shows up in the
database um and is provided to the town
or the Ward City that they used to live
in so that that that voter's name can be
automatically removed by the
supervisors uh in that
situation um I don't know if that
answered your question but but uh but
there is a lag between the time that you
know you have a a big wave of election
day
registrations and then cleaning up the
duplicates that exist because those same
voters are still on the checklist in the
old town that they came from thank you
representative thank you madam chair
thanks again Deputy for taking the
question I'd ask the prime form I'm
going to follow with you on this if we
keep any statistics or data to show same
day voter registrations for example
let's say in a particular town 200
people signed up to register to vote the
same day how many of those return in the
next election cycle out of you know we
keep any kind of data or statistic on
that uh we do have a voter history
um you know I'm sure because it's in the
database that some analysis can be made
of that
um you know if if you have more specific
questions I might be able to see if if
in aggregate form we can you know we can
pull some uh you know some
analysis okay thank you
yes thank you uh Madam chair and thank
you
secretary the
process which was described for
London it how widespread is that I know
I mean I could give you an anecdotal
example
but the 10
year when I I question
this process before the 10e scrub was
the extent of the process as it was
described to
me they uh appear to have been and the
sorts of things that are in this
legislation how widespread in the
state is a
more
forward positive
process
um if if I understand your your question
it's uh you know how many other towns go
through the process that Derry did um in
cleaning up their list you know I think
towns uh because we have a system that
relies on the local communities and the
local election officials to actually run
the elections whether it's uh taking
care of voter registrations and
maintaining the checklist at the local
level to actually running the
elections um they there are different
levels of of
um uh I'll say proactiveness in in
getting that job done and it it reflects
you know the people that are actually
doing the job and uh overall you know I
think it works well for the State of New
Hampshire I mean are there some areas
where you maybe the job isn't getting
done as it should absolutely um and then
you have the Other Extreme where you
know you have communities that are just
really keeping up with um you know with
the changes on the
checklist and and that's just it's
ingrained in our system um what I can
tell you is that you know we have had
exercises in uh in cleaning the list up
uh we did go through the effort probably
six uh six or so years ago where New
Hampshire participated in the interstate
cross check program uh that was
controversial at the time um but we did
receive uh I think it was 99,000 matches
of duplicate voters with the same name
same date of birth uh in in New
Hampshire and other states around the
country and uh after we paired through
we we actually spent the time to winnow
that down uh to just a few hundred
voters where uh you know we had to do
more research to make sure that that
those people were not the same
individual and what is amazing is how
many people in this
country have your name and your date of
birth it is it's it's
frightening um but but uh but getting
back to to the results I mean we
continued to pair that down to a list of
you know it was less than a hundred uh
where it did appear that there were uh
individuals same name same date of birth
voting in the same election uh in
different locations and with the
attorney general's review they did end
up
Prosecuting uh you know wasn't a lot of
people but um you know it it was enough
to say that you know there is there are
isolated instances of of uh fraudulent
voting out there um not on a grand scale
not organized but but in individual
cases there are people that try and game
the system and so that was an exercise
where you know we were able to you know
do some list cleaning uh you know verify
voters but it was incredibly time
consuming and and there are resources
you know in terms of Staff time and and
finances that are required to do that
and so you know these things can be done
but it also has to be recognized that
that there is a cost that goes along
with
that thank you further questions for
committee members questions committee
members standing
[Music]
online I'm not seeing any thank you scan
for speaking is there anybody else um I
see that Louise Spencer has her hand up
this will be the last public comment in
regards to this
hearing
[Music]
thank
you hi Miss Spencer go ahead hi thank
you I'm not sure what the cause of the
delay was but thank you again my name's
Louise Spencer I'm from conquered New
Hampshire um I hadn't initially intended
to speak but upon hearing the discussion
I just wanted to note a few things in
regard to deputy secretary scanlan's
testimony um which was regarding the
cross check process that the state went
through um it was an incredibly time
consuming process with many many many
false positives other in other words
people that were identified as po
potentially not being qualified voters
who upon further investigation were
determined to um in fact be um eligible
or to have legitimately moved um one way
or the other there is a um an
alternative solution that can help
provide um much useful d data in real
time and um your own colleague here on
this committee representative silver
mentioned it at a prior hearing and that
is the Eric system and this is a system
that um is expanding I believe there
there are well over 30 States now that
participate and share data there is also
information that come flows through the
DMV that identify voters that have moved
um both out of state and within the
state so that uh towns have the ability
to um would have the ability to keep
their checklists more up to date um this
is a critically important issue for the
Integrity of our
elections um it is uh I think we all
agree that it is essential that um we
have the most update uh up-to-date
information that we can have it saves um
tremendous amount of work for our
election officials who are already so
incredibly hardworking it's it's I I
think that was completely underscored by
uh the last election cycle and it also
helps ensure the public that um you know
to the extent possible that these roles
reflect all of those folks who are um
who are legitimately uh registered and
um you know
constitutionally um eligible voters so
uh I just wanted to add that point um
and I'm happy to send along additional
information about
Eric I'm happy to take
questions questions for anybody
attending onl
I'm sorry my H for committee members
just so you know is when I see you
unmute yourself that's when I know if
you haven't waved at me that's when you
have a question but I'm not seeing any
right now so thank you okay and I I'll
go ahead and send along some additional
information on Eric thank you very much
all right
uh I have I said that that was going to
be our last person I had nobody else
signed up and we 10 minutes over the
hearing I see that Mr Mr Meyer has
raised their hand if you can briefly
speak to the bill please I I understand
the cross check but that's not this bill
Mr
Meyer uh good morning members of the
committee uh my name is Lucas Meyer I
had previously planned on testifying on
this bill but any conation about Eric um
is one that I would love to lend my
voice to I'm here in a personal capacity
uh but just one point Miss Spencer's
comments um I Heard Deputy uh Secretary
of State scandin mention the time that
went into combing through sens of
records and false positives that were
sent with cross check EXC you said if
you're there in your professional
capacity are you here as a lobbyist or
on behalf of Eric UNC
confused I'm I'm sorry I I said personal
as a as a as a citizen I'm sorry the
mask makes my hearing bad I can't figure
it out all right
no worries uh uh but to the to Deputy uh
secretary about the time that went into
looking through the cross check data and
the staff costs associated with that
Eric for a um fee of around 20 to
$225,000 a year uh would provide the
Secretary of State's office with that
information uh within days after an
election which I think uh his staff
might app might appreciate there um
having to come through all that data by
just getting a file sent to Eric um so
just wanted to you know as I read
through this bill it really does touch
on a lot of the work Eric could do um
and at a much more coste efficient uh
price point Thank you thank you
questions for Mr Meyer committee members
attending in person or
online I'm not seeing anybody having
already said two speakers go is there
anybody else who wants to speak I I
don't want to need to cut people off um
is there anybody else who wants to speak
on this bill I'm not seeing anybody
raising their
hands so I'm going to close the public
hearing on House Bill
285 and I am going to open a public
326 this is the bill requiring town and
City cl to make electronic list of
persons who have requested been mailed
or returned absentee ballots available
to candidates upon upon request the
prime sponsor of this bill is
representative Barry who is with us in
this committee
welcome to introduce
this sign up that you're speaking on
this after the hearings today that would
be
great thank you mad chairman members 326
the bipar and hous Bill in a small way
modern the way conduct our elction
CA 2020 we saw a record number of Bot
request due to the covid-19 pmic while
2020 was certainly not a normal year
what is normal is the growing number of
abely B reest perent of the are
State sh increase in importance in
identifying voters and as a Cate early
we put you know that when somebody
requests an absente ballot that they are
going to vote in 2020 well over 90% of
abente ballots will returned as a
candidate we need to be able to contact
these voters in a kindly man once they
have passed their
vote in reality they're not taking it
back enter HB 326 this bill would
require that town clerk provid list of
ab request electronically if requested
by the candidate this is the list that
is already that is already currently
aable to candidates but what is not
required for the town clerks to provide
them electronically there are some Town
clerks who will withhold the list unless
the candidate or the representative
physically shows up at the office and
requests it with payment in
hand as we are currently in the
electronic page this isly ridiculous to
force candidates who in New Hampshire
are already volunteers to physically be
at the town clerk's office during work
hours is an unnecessary burden the
clerks all have electronic system and
record keeping so so simply forwarding
said L is not an undo or overbearing
request candidates for higher office and
candidates who represent multiple towns
should not be handicapped in attempting
to conduct more modern fastpaced
campaign one house be fun bills that
prohibit Town clerks from withholding
the list in Le of payment as there have
been issues in the past with some clerks
using that as an excuse to not provide
the list in a timely man I look forward
to hearing the committee's thoughts on
this and of course I urge the consider a
recommendation of to pass and I am happy
to take any
questions representative sweet thank you
madam chair and thank you representative
Barry for uh for testifying and taking
my question um you your bill would
essentially make it so that they would
email the list over to candidates
instead of printing them on paper so how
much paper do you think we would save
from being discarded in the environment
I don't know if quantify the amount of
paper we say but there is an
environmental impact to this bill you
know having people drive unnecessarily
to their town clerk's office to say hey
I'm here hand a list um that there's
going to be there's going to be an
Environ representative Brian thank you
madam chair have you heard anything from
clerks who say that this will cost their
Town's money I I don't know how this
will C to money they're already maintain
electronic list I believe State's office
actually assists them with maintaining
abute electronically um this is 2021 no
one has a paper L anymore if they're not
keeping this electronically that's a
whole another
problem further questions from committee
members in
attendance representative berser on yes
uh thank you madam chairman uh
representative just a couple quick
questions if I may um first how much
time do you think the clerk should have
have have to respond to a request for
this list um it's I it's the bill should
be but in my opinion should be a daily
response requested we're talking about
sending an
email okay a further question Madam
chair
representa um should there be
established a flat fee uh because I know
that cities and towns probably have
various fees if there were a flat fee
then payment perhaps could be paid
either by check or by credit card in
advance of releasing the information so
I did consider this um and I I would
love if there was a flat Fe across the
board based on the let's say the size of
the Town you're requesting it in right
there's obviously different record
keeping requirements for larger and
smaller town I did not include that in
this bill because I did not want that to
be reason not to pass it because do have
towns that set the cost of producing
documents largely for 918 and right to
no request and I didn't want you tangle
up into that debate if you feel that we
can pass that legislation on a thatly
basis I would be an enthusiastic
supporter of that I didn't want to
hinder the overall idea okay thank you
very much no further
questions thank you further questions
from any committee members on this
bill
I'm not seeing any representative here
thank you repr for introducing the bill
also signed up to speak on this bill is
Miss Robinson Miss Robinson I believe
you are with us as the welcome thank you
very much um I wanted can you hear me
yes we can but okay great thank you very
much sorry um I appreciate this bill
being considered and espe especially
having worked with a number of
candidates I wanted to Simply make a
clarification under line six of the bill
um it says electronic copies and I would
appreciate it if it could say electronic
data file what we have found in the past
is that uh yes Town clerks will provide
an electronic list and it is a PDF file
which is almost impossible to use and
requires if you're going to mail
somebody something uh to invite them to
uh vote for the candidate as with their
absentee ballot it requires transferring
all that information into
um an Excel file or something like that
that cannot be used as far as
electronically
manipulated and so that would be having
a sortable file would be really helpful
um and as to the question of the um cost
of the list I'd like to weigh in on that
as well and that is
that right now there is a ceiling on the
charge for the checklist which is
$25 and we have had uh at least in the
last uh election we had charges of a
dollar per uh page for the checklist and
even in the excuse me not for the
checklist for the absentee ballot list
and even in the case of Grantham of all
places um we had uh list that cost up to
$58 because we were looking at the cost
per page where if it were provided an
ass sortable data file it would just be
the same
price
regardless um so that would be really
helpful if we could have some
consistency there thank
you thank you M Robinson any questions
for M
Robinson I'm not seeing any questions so
thank you for staying with us and
joining us again my pleasure thank
you HB 326 is in regards to electronic
lists of absent to request persons is
there anybody else in attendance who
would like to speak to this
bill I have a couple of
people
um representative Lane did you have a
question and I missed
it I have a general question I probably
should have asked um the sponsors but my
my question
is I I'm going to show my ignorance here
why do you need this list what what's
the purpose purpose of getting the
absentee voter
list not really not very
well is this better representative yes
thank you
so let's take 2020 for for an example
where about 30% of the absentee ballots
are cast in an election so
in in 2020 alone uh because of the
covid-19 changes in the election law
voters were allowed to for the first
time request vote the primary and
general election abute ballot at the
same time right so if you know that 30%
of the ballots effectively in that
election are going to go out within a
week or two of the end of the primary
you have to know to get to those voters
quickly right because as candidates we
want to be able to make our pitch say
why you should vote for us right and I
understand that there's provision where
somebody sends in the M ballot they can
show up to the polls on Election Day
Before 6 a.m. to change it we all know
no one does that we all know that that's
just not a thing it's it's allowed but
voters don't know they can do it and
they flly don't exercise the right so
when you're trying to convince voters to
vote for you you need to know who's
going to cast their vote and when and
you know when people are casting their
ballot you need to get to them early
versus people who are going to cast
their ballots on ele that you have more
time did that that sufficiently answer
that question yes thank
you I
have Danielle pre would like to speak in
regards
to this
bill Miss prey I believe you are with us
and all
set
just pray if you'd like to speak could
you raise your hand I've lost you on my
list up there you
are I apologize to committee members we
sort of having discussions about how to
do this pray you should be with us if
you unmute we will be all set sure I've
got a good morning um my name is
Danielle pray and I'm from Amhurst I was
a candidate last fall and I am in
support of this bill I just wanted to
give my uh a few of my experiences or my
experience um last fall I did request
the absentee ballot list from my town
clerk which which was fine they were
great getting it to me but my charge was
a little bit more than the previous
speaker I was charged a125 a page and in
our pretty small town of Amhurst 56
Pages came to $70 I believe so I I
definitely would have preferred an
electronic copy and not have to put out
funds for that I was on a pretty limited
budget for the um for the run for office
and I I think you'll you'll see support
all around from everyone that probably a
cap on that or or if the elect if this
bill passes electronic would be fine but
maybe consider a cap on the cost of uh
paper as
well so that's all I have well thank you
very much
does anybody have any questions from
M I'm not seeing any thank you for
joining us this morning is there anybody
else in attendance who would like to
make a comment on HB
326 I'm not seeing any so I'm going to
close the hearing on
3:26 and and in approximately 7 minutes
we will begin our next public hearing
and that will be on
h
unmuted excellent thank
you
and Madame chairman you may see
representative gay in the attendees list
I see that she did not um register in
time for the print out but she is oh now
she has her hand up also just making
sure you saw saw
her all
right good morning everybody the
election look committee is back in
session from our recess it is 11:30 we
have a hearing on HB
476 this is relative to election
officers at additional polling places
this bill removes the requirement that
election officials for an additional
polling place in a town to be domiciled
in the district of the additional
polling place we have representative
Betty gay with US Representative gay is
the prime sponsor of HB 476 welcome back
to election
representative thank you my heart half
my heart is there and the other half's
in the new the new committee so I just
presented a bill to transportation for
for election law um this this bill is
passed our committee last
year 100% And it passed the house but
then it died of covid before it could
make it to the Senate so this is this
bill is to make um um to make our
moderator happy and the moderators and
town Clerks of all the towns that have
multiple voting
districts um because the current law
makes it illegal to H uh to hire
assistant moderators and assistant Town
clerks from anywhere but exactly the
voting district where they're
working well well it's really hard in a
town of 30,000 to get four extra skilled
people to work so um we our our
moderator said I really don't like
breaking the law but I have to do it
could you change this so we just simply
Chang the word that they lived in that
District to they live in the
town thank
you oh and the wording extra I'm sorry
the then they thought they would add
this add to it so it's not just towns
they put the same uh Freedom into uh
Wards because they're similar you know
equivalent to
towns thank you are there questions for
representative gay multiple term member
of the election previously in regards to
HB
questions from people attending
online representative L yes thank you
hello representative gay um I have a
question about section two of the bill
it says that each assistant moderator
and assistant clerk shall have their
domicile in the city Ward where they
were served I wouldn't it be in the city
where they live to make it equivalent to
what the town is wouldn't it just be the
city rather than the ward because I know
I have a very small Ward and I know that
our moderator has a problem getting
people that live in the
ward actually I'm gonna ask
representative vergon to chime in on
this given his uh experience in NASA
because I have same thing occurred to me
when I looked at it but I'm not
pro um sure Madam chair be happy to um a
City ward is a uh single voting district
in the same way the town is uh as I
interpreted this if a City ward wanted
to have an additional polling place it
could do so uh and then it would fall
within the same kinds of guidelines and
parameters that are being outlined for a
town um in other words a an assistant
moderator working at a second place
within a ward is still a registered
voter in that ward in the same way that
they uh an assistant moderator in the
town of uh Bedford uh was working at an
additional place there's still a
registered voter in the town of Bedford
um so we we can't have I don't think we
can have people moving uh out of one
Ward to work in another they're they're
essentially then moving from uh Bedford
to Goffstown for example to help out the
people in gtown I don't know if that
that helps clarify anything but that's
my understanding of of state
law thank you for that clarification
representative gay is still on the floor
are there any questions for
representative gay from
anyone I'm not seeing any thank you for
coming this morning representative gay
thank you it's so great to see everybody
nice to see you um representative gay if
you could go on the electronic
registration as speaking for this bill
that would be great okay is there
anybody else in attendance who wants to
speak to this
bill there is anybody else in attendance
if they could please raise their
hand I'm not seeing anybody so that
completes Our Testimony this morning on
HB
476 um so I'm going we're going to go
into a recess now until 12 o'clock again
my apologies uh the struggling with the
scheduling here obviously and I'm sorry
for the inconvenience to members we will
be speaking with each
other
e
we are
unmuted welcome everybody back to the
New Hampshire house selection Law Public
hearings for this date it is noon and we
have a public hearing scheduled on HB
523 HB
523 requires voter who register to vote
by using a qualified voter affidavit or
sworn statement on the election day
registration form to have their
photograph taken at the time of
registration I have as an
attendee representative Betty gay who is
the Prime sponsor of this bill so
representative J welcome back this to
oure you one you I think we're all
set okay I finally finally was able to
unmute greetings everybody thank you
madam chair um it's a very very short uh
a very short Bill requiring a person who
registers to vote without identification
has to have their photo made uh and this
was inspired because we already know
that if you're voting and you don't have
uh a photo ID you can fill out the uh
the same kind of affidavit that you can
use to register to vote and uh then they
want to take your picture but you can
refuse if you can say with a straight
face that it's against your
religion and uh the reason this bill was
submitted is that there is no current
bill no current RS say right now that
requires a photo if you register to vote
with use by using
affidavits um and so excuse me so this
was for two reasons number one to say
that you should have a photo
and the other uh is to say well one is
to say you that's part of the procedure
but the other is to take away that
option to say oh it's against my
religion I'm sorry if it's against your
religion bring in some kind of proof of
who you are so um
um I guess that's the simple as it is uh
you can ask me questions to fill in the
holes thank you representative gay are
there members of the committee
here
who have questions members of the
committee attending
remotely Madame chair may I say one more
sentence Okay the reason that this is
submitted is I was not aware but um I'm
I met a new rep who was working at a
poll in November and a a group of like
college age people came in he said 20
something that he did not recognize they
came in as a group they said we want to
register we don't have any ID none of
them claimed to have any ID so they gave
them the affidavits and then they said
we're take your picture and they said oh
no we don't want to have our picture
made so they got to vote and
leave and so when I talked with um I was
checking out the validity of my bills so
when I CH talked to Deputy scanland he
said that should have been reported to
us is he still here I'm
hoping is Deputy scanland still here so
anyway there there he is he's just not
sitting in front of his computer so I
would like to hear you know it would be
helpful if he says explains this but
that was my understanding that uh they
sh they shouldn't have been permitted to
do that but it's not in statute it's in
statute that you take the picture when
you're voting but not this just fills it
in and says when you're registering so
thank you thank you any questions from
committee
members present or attending
online
so representative gay just I think you
did summarize what I understand the bill
to do as compared to the current photo
requirement when you
vote an
ID this is a photo requirement for when
you register with outer voter ID
regardless of the app correct
[Music]
yes
represent thank you thank you madam
chair I just had a quick question about
that anecdote concerning the um 20-some
so what town um or polling place uh did
that um did that happen at and according
to the representative who conveyed the
story thank
you
Madam chair go ahead representative G
I'm sorry I don't know I didn't I didn't
ask him when he told us right Al I
should have called him and asked him to
call in
today all right thank you um
representative Veron yes thank you madam
chairman representative gay welcome back
um just a a quick question is is it your
intention that this voter would have his
or her photo taken twice once at the
voter registration table then have to go
through the process again at the
checklist table or is it your intent
that it's just done once but it's done
at the voter registration uh table uh
first or
only well I wish I had thought of that
um because it would be silly to take it
take the picture twice but if they do
have to attach the photo it's like polar
Ides it's a different brand but I did
learn that uh the state provided the
cameras and that's what's in the FI they
still have the cameras uh uh Deputy
scandin did his best to figure to make a
guess at how many they'd have to replace
as well as the cost of the film um you
do attach the picture to the document so
for a person who is
registering and then voting
um I guess they would have to take the
picture twice because there there would
be two
documents but that's not really my my
field that's really a moderator
question okay thank
you further questions from committee
members I'm not seeing any thank you
representative gay is there anybody else
in attendance today for House Bill 523
who would like to
speak Madam chair if I might this is uh
David scandin deputy secretary of state
and I just wanted to comment a little
bit on the fiscal note um you know this
pretty much reflects the cost of
purchasing the cameras for the photo ID
law that went into effect in
2012 and uh that system once it was
implemented uh worked really well to the
point that uh you know very few voters
going through the polling place without
an acceptable form of ID end up having
their photo taken because they they have
an ID that that works for
them the thinking with this legislation
was that there would be more photos
taken uh because of Voters that
otherwise would fill out a qualified
voter affidavit to prove
identity um you're requiring a
photograph being taken of them um and it
would probably be easier at that point
to have the photo taken at the
registration table as opposed to a
central place um uh you know where the
voters are doing the same thing to
obtain a ballot um because there would
be more photos taken and there might be
additional cameras needed in a polling
place especially larger polling places
um you know it may also shorten the life
of the cameras that uh we purchased in
2012 and you know they're they're now
approaching a decade old and at some
point are going to need to be replaced
anyway so um I just want to say if the
committee decides that this is
appropriate uh you know I think it's
doable um there will be a a minimal cost
for additional cameras and um I'd be
happy to answer any
questions questions forut scanland
representative thank you madam
chair uh Deputy scanland how many
people um wanted a religious exemption
in the last election that you're aware
of they did not want their photograph
taken because it was graveen
image I don't have that number but I but
I'm I'm sure it's a very low
number follow up follow when you mean
when you say low do you mean lower than
a thousand 100 10 have a GU
estimate
um just an educated guess you know I'd
say it's less than a 100 um you know it
less than it's just a fraction of 1% of
Voters that need to have their photo
taken because they don't have an
acceptable form of ID and so those that
are claiming the religious exemption
would would be a fraction of that so
it's a it's a number that certainly is
less than 100 representative growan that
answered my question M representative
bar than SC thank you for being here
today um the last time we testified on a
bill about registering I asked you if a
person who had been in the state for 30
seconds could walk into the polling
location present no ID no proof of down
asile not have their picture taken and
have their ballot passed and you
explained that the answer to that
question is is effectively yes right
correct
yes um would this bill in the opinion of
secretary state's office at least move
us an inch in the direction towards some
voter Integrity measures because
currently it is my understanding that we
have the loosest election laws in the
country well this this is a balancing
act and and The Balancing Act is making
it easy for voters to vote but at the
same time making sure that the voters
that are voting are qualified to vote
and so to the extent that you make the
process easy um you know you may have to
take some steps to be able to verify uh
on the other end and I would see this as
a tool uh you know to just
verify uh in a process that um you know
in New is fairly easy to
do thank you representative Lane did I
see you with the hand up yes I did
um even though you're it's a balancing
act at P scalin would you um say that
there's rampant fraud or that we've seen
any evidence of
that
uh we know and as I mentioned in my
earlier testimony today on another bill
that there are isolated instances
have been prosecuted recently by the
Attorney General's office where uh
voters have uh exercised that right
inappropriately and um and in some in
instances they voted in you know more
than one election have voted more than
one time in the same election so we do
know that it exists uh we do not have
any evidence that there this is
happening on a large scale or an
organized scale
okay thank you further questions from
committee members representative to ro
thank you madam chair thank you Deputy
for taking the questions so in your
opinion um if we were to enact this
legislation would would taking a photo
be helpful and reducing numbers of
people that do
this
inappropriately well I I I think it's a
check on the system I I think if a if a
photograph is required at the Reg
rtion uh table or voters get used to the
fact or know that they're going to have
to provide some form of identification
or have a photo taken um our experience
with the voter ID to obtain a ballot has
been that the voters seem to find the
documentation that they
need thank you thank you further
questions for Deputy
scan mam chair representative Sweeney
thank you madam chair thank you deputy
scandin for uh for being here with us
and answering our questions uh last year
it was uh it was made news that in 2016
there was a gentleman from West Lebanon
New Hampshire uh who had voted in the
2016 presidential election uh left the
poing location put on a wig in his car
and then went back into the ploy
location and voted under the identity of
a of a female uh that he had by all
accounts concocted up a life story for
um if we had this P process in place
during the 2016 election where when he
went in to register as this new
individual uh do you think would have
been potential with the photograph that
it wouldn't have taken four years to for
the Attorney General's office to find
and discover this this case of motor
fraud uh yeah ver Sweeney I I don't know
that I know the answer to that whether
it would have taken any less time to
come to that conclusion it's probably a
better question asked the attorney
General's
office thank you thank you further
questions from committee
members seeing none I'm going to close
the public hearing House Bill
523 we election law committee members we
have a uh noticed executive session at
1:30 we will be taking up the bills as
listed in the calendar hb11
1505 105
127 and
483 and with that have a nice lunch
everybody M chair I've been asked to
deliver pizza to this honorable
committee
really
e
M chairman we are unmuted and our video
is back on all right welcome everybody
the election committee is back in
session it is 1:30 on 2:12 PM are you
with
us I am I am I'm right here all right I
just wanted to make sure because that's
what showing in the middle of my big
screen now a different view on my
computer so I wanted to
so we have been noticed for executive
session this afternoon we're going to uh
EX in order the bills as noticed in the
calendar and the first bill that I would
like to present our executive session on
is HB
f
representa
there a second I'll second the
motion seconded
by
representative we're having I'm having
trouble
understanding
yes
he or representative bro and you are
having a hard time
understanding Madam
chairman now I can't hear
you um I I could not hear understand you
I couldn't understand who was making the
motions let me I'm sorry let me go back
I I turned this little red light was on
and I turned off at lunch time and I to
back
on um representative
Madam chair and fellow committee members
the clear intent of the United States
Constitution is individual state
constitutions establish the laws govern
governing their elections including the
establishment voting districts for
elective officers clear New Hampshire
Constitution that
the legisl has responsibility for to
assign this responsibility I believe
contrary TOS
of United
States defire has largest legislative
United stes in this house repres of
less adults in our state that makes
us
this
task
Constitution do that task deliberately
and carefully not delegate it appointed
commission contrary to our
constitution anybody else that would
like to speak to the
motion I'm looking at people who are
unmuted
representative unmuted would you like to
speak to the motion uh no I'm sorry
madam chair I had my hand up because I
wasn't hearing the speakers and in fact
I'm still having trouble hearing some of
the speakers all right I'm hearing a
little
background I'm sorry representative mad
did you to the
motion no pleas he just muted himself I
did just call um Ryan dorington from the
IT department to come see if he could
help out with um sound issues just on
his
way because I think everything is the
same as this morning representative Lane
did you want to speak to the motion no I
was just also saying we couldn't even
understand what the motion
was even when I repeated it with the mic
on yes All right so there's something
else going
on it does seem clear right this minute
you know just now you are speaking I I
am personally able to understand
you madam chair might I suggest that you
restate the
motion thank you representative Cody the
motion on the
floor is to move in expedient to
legislate HB 121
FNA
sort of watching the door to see if he
appears is there anybody who would like
to speak to this
motion I'm not seeing anyone so
therefore I'm going to ask the clerk to
call the
role representative
well yes I go yes represent McDonald
yes
represent Cody
no
Hammer no
no he needs to un on
phone I'm not sure he no no I'm sorry I
did not hear my name I think it might be
if you ask for representive Mir head
it's no thank you thank you
representative
yes what's the results of the
vote so the motion to it the motion to
itl passes 11
to9 the next bill for this consider for
this committee to consider is
h505 this would be allowing voters to
vote for multiple candidates for an
office is there a motion for this
representative Barrett uh yes Madam
chairman I move that the we make this
Bill to legisl so the motion on the
floor for 505 is itl is there a second I
second the motion mam chair
representative ter roian has seconded it
representative Barry would you like to
speak to your motion yes Madam chairman
I believe HB 505 would add unnecessary
confusion to the uh to the to the ballot
voters already have enough difficulty as
it is with the ballot and this would not
accomplish the goal the stated goal of
the SP of the bill
sponsors thank you is there anybody else
in the committee room who wants to speak
to this
bill anybody attending electronically
who wants to speak to this
bill I'm not seeing any hands or anybody
indicating they want to speak so I'm
going to ask the clerk to call the role
the motion is inex iedi to legislate
h505
represent
yes
yes yes
represent
yeses
yes was that burger on I'm
sorry
yeses Sandler
did you say hamblet
represent he's
muted on HL or S got it yes thank you
representative
s okay representative
Hammer Hammer yes hmer thank you
uh representative
Lane
yes representative
frus
Hamet
yes representative
Hamlet
Mirad
yes hey so
that's Madam Madam represent Griffin
yes that's everyone what's the vote
please okay so that is um 20 so the vote
on HB 505 is 20 to
zero uh I would like to put that on the
consent calendar if everyone is in
agreement yes
all right so 505 will go on the consent
calendar 20 to nothing
itl what have we got here election ches
for20 can you ask him to email them also
to the committee because the only people
here will get it okay I will do that all
right for a little break in the action
um we should all have the blue
2021 election law handbook I queried
about a supplement for changes to the
law because there are some things that
are not in it and what they do in the
off year is they print them in a sheet
so that you have them to supplement your
books they have just been delivered to
the committee room and I have asked that
they be email to everybody on the
committee so if you're present you could
pick up a paper copy if you want want
but all committee members should be
getting a copy and you would use that
with your RSA book on Election laws it
reflects the changes that were made from
last year because I think if you've been
watching a couple of the OS bills we
have have modified a bill but if you go
to the statute as printed it's not
exactly the same and that's why so that
was what that was all about so thank you
for allowing me to interrupt to address
that the next item is House Bill
105 House Bill 105 is relative to
political contributions by limited
liability
companies um is there a motion on House
Bill HB
105 yes Madam chair representative swee
yes Madam chair I move that HB 105 as
inexpedient to legisl
is there a second I'll
second so HB 105 has been moved to itl
by representative Sweeny and it has been
seconded by representative McDonald
representative Sweeney would you like to
speak to your motion yes thank you madam
chair uh the state of New Hampshire does
not track or list the membership of
registered llc's and therefore this
proposed change would not be enforcable
further in numerous United States
Supreme Court decisions campaign
contributions have been seen as an act
of free speech protected under the First
Amendment of the United States
Constitution therefore we as the house
election law committee and as a
legislative body should avoid placing
any further limits on our current system
of campaign finance and ensure that
entities such as llc's can continue to
practice their political autonomy and
expression as currently
allow thank you is there anyone else who
like to speak to the motion on the which
is itl
I'm not seeing anybody indicating they
want to
speak so I'm going to ask the clerk
representative Wells call to
vote representative McDonald yes
representative BR O'Brien yes
representative Sweeney yes
representative Hayward yes
representative Mooney yes representative
toosan yes representative Barry yes
representative gr yes representative quy
yes yes representative Cody
no representative Ward no representative
bon no representative Sandler
no representative HR
I say it
right representative Hammer
Hammer no what happened
muted oh thank you um
no representative
Lane representative Lane sorry couldn't
unmute
no Representative
frus
no Representative hamblet
no representative
Mirad
no representative Griffin
yes that would be 11
to9 HB 105 the motion to
itl carries I apologize uh will there be
Minority Report on HB
105 yes mam chair I believe so and for
121 also I would believe so um I have
not checked with the sponsor who I
suspect is going to do one in any case
but yeah I would think there would be
something of that kind I wouldn't put I
wouldn't put it on consent let's put it
that
way thank you
well it's it's important to have some
traditions every session so you all
right the next bill to to be voted on
this afternoon in the election law
committee is HB
465 465 is Rel
toiss by business organizations and
labor
unions motion on 465 representative ter
roian thank you madam chair is there a
second
what's your motion representative motion
is ined inexpedient to legislate H Bill
465 and is there a
second I'll second thank you
representative McDonald representative
toosan would you like to speak to you
yes thank you madam chair for some of
the reason you just heard on House Bill
105 this B was
problematic as you heard the Supreme
Court has ruled in the past with free
speech implications if this bill would
have passed most certainly would see
lawsuits Tri against the state of New
Hampshire doesn't treat all poies in an
equal manner certain comos of labor
unions comparison to what the LLCs could
do and also there exemptions for so
proprietorships so for that reason um I
recommend that we vote inexpedient
legislator
house
465 thank you thank you is there anybody
else that wishes to speak to the motion
for
465 nobody in person anybody
online I'm not seeing anything I'm going
to ask the clerk to call
vote representative McDonald yes
represent fome O'Brien yes
representative Sweeney yes
representative Hayward yes
representative Mooney yes representative
toosan yes representative Barry yes
representative gr yes representative qua
yes clerk is
yes representative Cody
no representative Ward no represent
berson no representative Sandler no
Representative
no representative Lane
no Representative
frus
no Representative hamblet
no representative
Mirad
no chairman Griffin
yes okay so it's 11 to9 the vote on 465
itl is 11 to9 will there be a Minority
Report once again Madam chair I've not
checked with the sponsor but in terms of
the priorities of the bills of this day
you won't see my name on
one thank will to
see the next do you need any excuse me
do you need anything from me we
have I'm
just all
right HB 391 is the next bill that is
scheduled
for V HB 391 increases the threshold for
reporting by political committees from
$100 um is there motion for HB 391
representative browan mam chair I move
we vote HB 391 on pass is there a second
second representative Terian seconds
would you like to speak to your motion
representative brow yes Madam chair our
current Law requires any contribution
above $25 to be reported this limit has
been in place since
1984 the purpose of this legislation is
to report potential Financial influence
on elections I think we can all agree
that in light of the funding levels of
elections today a single or aggregate
contribution of1 does not represent
undue influence on elections this bill
will also reduce the burden of reporting
by campaigns and especially in the house
where many campaigns have very small
contributions thank you madam
chair thank you representative does
anybody else wish to speak to the
motion anybody
electronically I'm not seeing anybody
indicating they want to speak further to
the motion I'm going to ask the clerk to
call the RO please representative
McDonald so this just for clarification
this is
hb1 391 and the motion
is representative McDonald
yes home O'Brien yes representative
Sweeny yes representative Hayward yes
representative Mooney yes representative
toosan yes representative F yes
representative Gro
yes quy
yes cler yes representative Cody
oh representative w
no representative B
no representative Sandler no
representative
Hammer representative
HR represent h no thank you no
no representative Lane
no Representative frus
no Representative hamblet
no representative
Mirad
no okay 11 to n
shair sorry representative Griffin
yes the vot is 11
to9 the vote 391 it's 11 to9
and a question on The Minority
Report the next bill that we are
executing with the chair's
apologies is HP 1227 we actually voted
on this last session in my excitement of
getting a bu I forgot that we had
already noticed it for a vote this
afternoon and at the request of the
clerk we
are going to see if there is any
interest in reconsidering the bill uh
but as of this point absent some further
dispositive motion the vote last
week is likely going to stand is there a
motion on 127 representative thank you
madam chair I make a motion to
reconsider on House Bill
127 is there a
second been seconded by for Wells um the
vote on
127 I'm sorry repres Ro speak yes um m j
indicated jumped it down a little
bit check this bill L committeee to
comply with the calendar schedule having
bill on this week I motion to
reconsider compliance there and I
recommend that you vote no
reconsideration thank you is there any
further discussion
on7 can I just get something clarified
Madam chair it's not contemplated that
there should be a different uh
resolution of that bill is there before
I vote on
reconsideration I I would expect that
there are so far going to be at least 11
no votes on this because the the report
has been written and I not aware of
anything other than the chair's
negligence scheduling and voting uh that
would have any impact on this
vote okay thank you madam
chair representa just for the record the
vote last week was 18 to
zero I remember the vote thank
you right um so I'm gonna ask the clerk
to call the
r
the motion is to
reconsider so we have representative
McDonald
no representative fut O'Brien
notive Sweeny no representative Hayward
no representative Mooney no
Representative toosan no representa
Barry no representative Gro no
representative quy
no no representative Cody no
representative Ward no representative
bon no representative Sandler no
representative
HR
no representative Lane no representative
frus
representative
frus believe she's saying no sorry no
no representative HL
no representative
Mirad
no representative Griffin
no that's 20 so the motion to reconsider
is 20 to not we do not need to write
anything f for the calendar the only the
calendar will the original V thank you
everybody for your indigence on that I
apologize uh the next item is
h43
C
advertising
is there a motion on 4 representa thank
you madam
chair a motion that House Bill 483 is in
expedient legisl is there a
second second the motion representative
quy seconds the motion so the motion on
the floor for 483 is inexpedient to
legislate representative ter Roan would
you like to speak to your motion yes
thank you madam chair
this bill for me was problematic is that
it basically
restricted candidate to be had in an
inment from free speech on what or how
he may have voted on some legislation so
if this bill if we pass would violate
the First Amendment right of a new
candidate by not allowing them to say
how they might have voted or would vote
on an issue but another candidate that
was an incumbent to have that right so
would certainly create a unfair uneven
playing
fi so for that reason recomend
vote legis
thank anybody else like to speak to this
bill
representative thank you uh I started
off feeling very sympathetic to this
bill um because in my own election I
experienced a situation where um a
letter was sent out full of inaccuracies
about my own record and one of them for
example was that I voted against Granite
Hammer when I actually voted in favor of
granite Hammer so I was sympathetic to
this bill but people can check that
record of mine and there were other
things in here that they can't check
that it's kind of crazy but um people
could also call
so they could check that uh with with
this
situation they can make an assumption
that because the person is not actually
B in office you can't say how they would
or would not
vote um I agree that the First Amendment
issues are are Paramount so I will be
voting um
it anybody else like speak to this
representative I want to thank sponsor
Bo this well legislation um I think he
makes extremely valid points about the
way political advertisement is going and
the lies that are told about people
however there are serious First
Amendment concerns so I will be voting
down thank you is there anybody else
wants to
speak not see anything so there's a
motion on the floor for HB
43 recommend to the house that it be
voted inexpedient to legislate to ask
the clerk to take the
role representative McDonald
yes representative fru home O'Brien yes
representative Sweeney yes
representative Hayward yes
representative Mooney yes
representative yes representative Barry
yes representa BR yes representative quy
yes FL says yes representative Cody
yes representative Ward yes
representative berson yes
representative yes representative
hmer
yes representative
Lane
frus yes yes representative hamblet yes
and representative
newad
yes
yes 20 to Zer thank you the vote on 483
is 20 to z i L that
will no objection that will go in the
consent calendar my computer just died
so I can no longer see you if you're so
you must speak up if anybody wants to
I'm not hearing anything so that will go
in the
consent I believe that concludes our
executive session business for today and
our committee business for today our
meeting next week will be on Wednesday
the calendar is out um it was pointed
out to me that hb21 is in the calendar
again um I did not submit 121 to be in
the calendar uh it was some concern over
I I'm not quite sure what happened I
will check with the clerk's office my my
concern is we're going to have to do
another motion to
reconsider um but I will let the know
that before we begin that
session we are doing a public uh
executive session first thing in an
attempt to get the the committee reports
on the that first bill in the calendar
for the following week we will have
public hearings and then we will have
executive session again in the
afternoon if anything else comes up in
the meantime please let me know and I
will let you know in regards to the
process
and does anybody have any other
questions before we adjourn this
afternoon I'm not seeing anything we are
adjourned thank you very much everybody
and have a nice
weekend